[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag émission
politique verte et france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec aurélie
gros conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
et présidente de la france vraiment face
à vous florian philippot conseil
régional du grand est et président des
patriotes
invité sur ce plateau également michel
scarbonchi ancien député européen et
membre du mouvement républicain et
citoyen merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france et c'est à la
une cette semaine regarder le recadrage
du ministre de l'intérieur aux policiers
lundi lors de ses voeux christophe
castaner leur a conseillé un usage juste
et proportionnée de la force on ne fait
pas de croche-pied à l'éthique at il
déclaré certains syndicats de police ont
fustigé un lâchage et un changement un
changement de 4 à visée électorale le
lendemain la famille de cédric joue via
le chauffeur livreur mort par plaquage
au sol le 5 janvier dernier a été reçue
place beauvau elle a demandé au ministre
la suspension immédiate des policiers
impliqués l'écouté
il n'a pris aucune décision et n'a
apporté aucune réponse aux
interrogations de la famille et des
avocats et notamment la demande
éventuelle de suspension des
fonctionnaires de police impliqués dans
le décès de cédric joue via mais
également l'interdiction puisque nous
avons solennellement demandé tout au
moins un moratoire éventuellement une
interdiction des techniques
d'immobilisation qui ont conduit à son
décès là aussi aucune réponse et aucune
décision ne sera prise visiblement
florian philippot à quoi a servi selon
vous le fait de recevoir la famille shaw
via place beauvau est ce que c'était de
la com est-ce que c'est dans la
l'affichage en tout cas d'un apaisement
voulu avec usage de la force par les
policiers que ce soit sur les
manifestations ou lors d'interpellations
comme on a vu je crois qu'il ya eu une
émotion très important dans le pays sur
cette affaire là parce qu'en plus la
vidéo on la voit donc on voit quasiment
sa mort en direct on a choisit pas la
diffuser plus que les images sont
difficiles mais je crois que bon
quasiment tout le monde l'a vu en
réalité et c'est vrai que pour l'instant
ça n'a servi à rien mais c'est vrai
qu'on a on a vu un changement de
discours de la part du ministre castaner
et du président la république
depuis ce moment là alors que ça fait
des mois et des mois et plus d'un an
qu'on a vraiment des comportements
absolument inadmissible je veux dire moi
je veux dire j'en parle en connaissance
de cause je connais personnellement des
manifestants parfaitement pacifique ont
perdu un oeil en france en dans les
manifestations est tout à fait avec à
cause d'un lbd et c'est vrai qu'il ya
tellement pas eu de réaction pendant
longtemps pas une suspension d'un
fonctions de police l'igpn qui bondit gp
est une vaste blague qui évidemment
l'igpn là aucune aucune indépendance ce
qu'on fait croire cela aux français ne
connaissent pas du tout ministère
l'intérieur l'igpn c'est un décalque du
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur barre
et est par ailleurs
justice qui n'avance pas très vite sur
ces sujets là non plus alors qu'elle a
été beaucoup plus rapide à embastiller
certain âge il est jaune est bien
certain ce certains cowboys moi je les
appelle comme ça parce que je veux
justement les stigmatiser pour protéger
les autres moi je protège l'immense
majorité de la police républicaine et de
la gendarmerie qui est parfaitement
républicaine qui est parfaitement
professionnelle qui doit pas être
amalgamée avec ces gens là mais les
cowboys et les gens qui ont eu ce genre
de comportement se sont sentis tout
permis tout permis parce que quoi qu'il
fasse quoi qu'il dise il y avait de
toute façon un ministre qui était là
pour les soutenir et des enquêtes qui
n'avançait pas eh bien on a on est
arrivé à certains drames une image
internationale de la france qui est
beaucoup dégradée à cause de cela et
même quelques dictatures qui s'amusent à
jouer avec cela en nous faisant elles
sont régulièrement
ben c'est presque de bonne guerre j'ai
envie de dire hé hé hé hé là bon au
moins aller on va voir ça a commencé à
bouger dans le discours j'espère qu'il
va y avoir des décisions prises
extrêmement rapidement alors on avait vu
effectivement les syndicats de police
réagir aurélie gros qui ont dénoncé un
un lâchage de la part de christophe
castaner pourquoi ce type de
déclarations maintenant à deux mois des
élections municipales
certains dénoncent vous allez le voir à
l'écran justement d un assouplissement
un fléchissement en tout cas de la
politique gouvernementale à visée
électorale est ce que c'est votre
sentiment
je crois honnêtement que le gouvernement
reçoit cette famille qui est
je veux dire c'est inacceptable personne
n'ira cautionner de tels actes mais
aujourd'hui les déclarations qu'a fait
le président de la république il faut
quand même rappeler que le président de
la république et gardiens de nos
institutions
il est gardien de nos institutions à
double titre d'une part pour pour
permettre le droit de manifester de
droit de grève le droit des citoyens en
tout cas de se faire entendre et par
ailleurs pour tout ce qui est des
questions de sécurité
et aujourd'hui il y a une problématique
effectivement dans les forces de l'ordre
qui est liée à deux choses la première
c'est que je crois que nous nos
policiers et nos gendarmes sont dans un
état de fatigue puisque la france a à
jamais connu autant de grèves à
répétition ça fait un an et demi que
tous les samedis ils sont mobilisés avec
un exercice fin en fin de compte de la
sécurité dans ces manifestations qui
sont elles pas forcément très organisée
et donc effectivement on observe des
dérapages et des dérapages qui sont
souvent des énormes fautes
professionnelles c'est pour ça que moi
je redis une chaise lax qu'il devra
aussi arrêter de mariage qui vient bien
sûr il faut arrêter de rencontre avec le
terme violences policières
je trouve que ça amalgame trop nos
forces de sécurité qui font par ailleurs
un travail extraordinaire tout au long
de l'année dans plein de situations je
rappelle que quand même là notre notre
principal liberté c'est cette sécurité
est aujourd'hui dire que c'est un coup
de communication que le gouvernement par
visées électorales fléchir et un peu moi
je ne pense pas je pense que merci enfin
de prendre conscience qu'il ya des
familles qui souffrent et c'est aussi le
travail d'un ministre de l'intérieur que
de recevoir ces familles là et quand il
se passe un accident tel que celui là et
aussi de prendre conscience qu'il ya des
policiers qui se sont des êtres humains
en trad mais qu'il faut être de recevoir
la famille de cédric joue via c'est pas
un message contradictoire que justement
le ministre envoie aux forces de l'ordre
on a vu les réactions qui se sait moi
moi je ne trouve pas que ce soit un
message contradictoire il va auprès
d'une famille d'un jeune homme qui est
décédé avec un policier
il ya pour moi fait une faute grave
puisque cet homme est mort donc par
conséquent il n'y a pas d' excuses à la
mort d'un policier ne sont pas du
personnage
oui là pour le coup on est d'accord les
policiers devraient être suspendus et je
pense qu'il ya deux choses il ya d'une
part ne pas stigmatiser l'ensemble de
nos services de police en france d'autre
part que le ministre s'intéresse aux
citoyens aussi qui souffrent et là je
crois qu'il n'y a pas plus grande
souffrance que ce que peut vivre cette
famille est par ailleurs être très ferme
sur les questions de deux fautes dans
dans les systèmes de police qui entache
l'ensemble de la police en france je
voudrais qu'on regarde une vidéo à
présent je vous ferai réagir michel
scarbonchi cette vidéo à toulouse où
l'on avait vu justement là un crs fait
un croche-pied à une jeune femme qui
était à côté à côté d'eux qui a fait
beaucoup réagir et qui a un fait que
effectivement l'opinion publique
s'interroge en tout cas sur ces
violences
2 certains policiers on voit justement
cette jeune femme tombée le jeu de mots
le mauvais jeu de mots de christophe
castaner on ne fait pas de croche-pied à
l'éthique c'est ce qu'il a dit lors de
ses voeux aux policiers franchement je
pense et quads cet humour 600 m je pense
pas qu'il ait fait que de l'humour in a
écouté nos forces comme aurélie gros
viens de le dire nos forces de police
sont mobilisées depuis 18 mois
de façon intensive comme jamais
probablement dans la république cela ne
s'est passé il faut peut-être remonté à
1936 pour retrouver des situations
analogues et on assiste à quoi on
assiste un à deux choses d'abord des des
manifestations de plus en plus violente
des manifestants de plus en plus violent
avec u16 mme un an sauvagement une haine
qu'on a rarement connu
moi j'ai fait des défilés une
exaspération peut-être pour des alors
que ce soit lié l'exaspération à de la
colère légitime à d'autres choses etc
mais je considère moi que ça participe
de l'ensauvagement de notre société
qu'on peut vérifier à à tous les jours à
tous niveaux
les incivilités il suffit de ce premier
lancement il ya une détresse sociale et
pas il n'y a pas que la détresse sociale
il ya probablement liée aussi aux
nouvelles technologies ni aussi à
l'information immédiate et sait donc où
la réactivité beaucoup plus fort est ce
que je constate c'est que d'un côté on a
des manifestants de plus en plus
organisée de plus en plus violents et de
l'autre côté on a des forces de police
sous tension mais surtout qu'ils ont un
défaut mois pour moi le le défaut en
dehors des violences qui ont été
soulignés et cetera
c'est que quand vous regardez comment
sont entraînés nos militaires que ce
soit des forces usuels ou des forces
spéciales et quand vous regardez
d'entraînement de la police
on est vraiment il ya un gouffre
terrible donc un problème de formation
un problème d'entraînement il faut
consacrer aux forces de police
le temps nécessaire pour former
correctement les gens ont peut pas
demander à des gens d'utiliser des
techniques nouvelles des armes nouvelles
et cetera sans qu'il y ait une formation
préalable et tué tous les excès des
dérapages qui ont eu lieu ils viennent
de ça quand vous êtes pris dans une
manifestation qu'on vous êtes agressé
par des des gens avec des bâtons qui
vous fera ou qui veulent vous vous tuez
carrément vous tuer quand j'ai des gens
qui vous créé en vous regardant suicidez
vous et cetera
mais il faut pas s'attendre à ce qu'un
policier réagissent naturellement même
si les former pour être calme patient
etc
donc vous êtes sûr vous allez avoir des
excès des dérapages donc je crois que le
premier travail à faire c'est celui de
la formation de l'entraînement de
l'encadrement de nos forces de police
alors les discours a changé 1 c'est le
l'angle de ce débat on a écouté
également et emmanuel macron mercredi
lors des voeux à la presse il s'est
adressé également aux forces de l'ordre
alors envoyé ce message écouté il y à
une violence de rue qui s'est installée
dans notre pays dont on avait vu les
premières traces au moment d'ailleurs de
l'occupation de notre dame des landes
qui avait pris un nouveau tour au moment
des événements et des des manifestations
de 2016 et qui s'est fortement
développée ces derniers mois il nous
faut évidemment non seulement la
réprimer la combattre avec beaucoup de
clarté la sanctionner à chaque fois
qu'elle existe et je serai intraitable
sur le sujet emmanuel macron qui va dans
votre sens saint michel scarbonchi il ya
une violence de rue at il dit la
violence est elle uniquement dans la rue
florian philippot est ce qu'il n'ya pas
une violence aussi delà de la politique
menée par le gouvernement dans le
jusqu'au boutisme en tout cas constatés
par certains qui manifestent aujourd'hui
dans la rue je pourrais expliquer un peu
les choses
la tête de louis saez a été coupée
personne ne semble s'en réjouit mais
c'est un phénomène historique qui
s'expliquait par un contexte du plein de
rebondissements je préfère l'histoire la
révolution française et plein de phases
différentes plus ou moins violentes
parfois ultra violente
ce qu'on vit de l'anaem avoir et ultra
sanguinaire d'ailleurs aimé ça a mené à
cela et puis des centaines et des
milliers d'autres
parce que il ya un phénomène historique
qui s'est déployée avec à l'origine
quand même des causes
il ya eu on peut faire l'histoire de la
révolution et de ce qui s'est passé
avant il ya des phénomènes historiques
objectif qui explique certaines choses
et alors on le voit a posteriori
évidemment que c'est pas il n'y a pas
une flambée de violence dans la société
française comme ça par hasard il n'y a
pas des gens qui se mettent en grève
pendant des mois qu'ils perdent de
l'argent au passage pour le faire par
hasard il n'y a pas des gens qui un jour
seront mis effectivement un gilet jaune
pour être plus visibles et puis sa
partie aussi le phénomène tout
simplement du prix de l'essence parce
que c'est le gilet jaune de
l'automobiliste par hasard et ça ne dure
pas par hasard depuis 62 actes c'est
qu'il ya une violence terrible aussi
dans le pays de social pouvoir d'achat
retraites salaires tout ce qu'on veut
terrible terrifiante
il faut se balader quand même en france
pour voir l'état de misère du pays et en
même temps il ya une violence ressenti
de la part de dirigeants qui ont le sens
du canton dans ce sentiment qu'il
méprise totalement le peuple qui
voudrait faire un dogme on n'écoute plus
on respecte pas le résultat des
référendums et résultats des zurichois
qu'il vote de toute façon sera la même
politique
donc évidemment qu'il faut comprendre
cela ça veut pas dire qu'on justifie des
violences certainement pas qu'on les
excuses
ça veut dire qu'il faut se replacer dans
une perspective un peu plus haute pour
essayer de comprendre un peu ce qui se
passe sur vous liszt effectivement oui
je suis d'accord et vous sur la
formation parce que beaucoup de
dérapages sont venus notamment de la bac
à bac n'est pas fermée au maintien de
l'ordre
voilà
coût - des gendarmes mobiles et des crs
- et c'est vrai que la bague c'est autre
chose c'est l'interpellation souvent
brutales soudaine parce que voilà c'est
leur métier et pas le maintien de
l'ordre donc là il ya un problème
d'usagé de formation mais si vous voulez
je pense que c'est pas simplement cela
je pense que moi je parle de violence
politique et policière parce que je
pense que c'est pas totalement par
hasard qu'on a vu ce qu'ils vont h
je pense que le pouvoir a notamment été
paniqués par ce mouvement des gilets
jaunes cantine était au plus haut fin
2018 et que des ordres ont été donnés
quand même d'aller beaucoup plus loin
que ce qu'on fait d'habitude d'avoir un
maintien de l'ordre beaucoup plus
violent ce cas il faut bien expliquer
sur la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
c'est aussi une des directives qui sont
donné un surnom je vais vous donner un
exemple très simple quand le préfet de
police monsieur l'allemand dit il répond
à une dalle qui pourtant truc qui
l'interpellent qui pacifique bon il lui
répond madame nous ne sommes pas du même
camp qu'un préfet de police disent nous
ne sommes pas du même camp c'est grave
mais ça veut dire beaucoup de choses ça
veut dire qu'il considère qu'il ya des
camps donc il ya des conflits
il ya des guerres il ya des
affrontements si l'aca dans la tête ça
se verra sur le terrain parce que c'est
lui le patron et c'est lui le patron
opérationnel en l'occurrence pour les
manifestations qui ont lieu à paris ou
en ile de france
donc je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
politique et je crois qu'il y a eu que
le gouvernement peut se les
manifestations sur le climat sont des
enjeux très importants mais une même
vision du climat ou même syndicale
compte avec la cfdt la cgt et fo ça on
connaît très bien bon saint paul entre
eux soit finalement tout ça le gros on
peut tolérer des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus spontané populaire qui
viennent comme cela il a attendu
agrégeant des gens qu'on ne voit jamais
normalement dans une manifestation qui
sont pas militants ça ça peut créer un
phénomène de panique chez les dirigeants
et donc les amener à prendre des
décisions politiques qui se traduisent
par des dérapages policiers
voilà j'ai essayé de faire clair mais
parce qu'il faut toujours quand on dit
cela ne pas comprendre que ça veut dire
qu'on justifie ou qu'on les violences
ont bientôt leurs deux côtés on essaie
d'expliquer que la violence ça ne vient
jamais à mon avis de nulle part belle à
michel scarbonchi agir agir non je
voulais peut-être que ce que nous vivons
tient au fait que pendant trente années
et sous trois présidents de la
république de droite comme de gauche
nous avons vécu une impuissance de l'est
à permanente des reculs permanent à
chaque réforme engagée rappelez vous dès
qu'il y avait des manifestations l'état
reculé donc les gens sont habitués à ce
jeu de rôle est là pour une fois où il
ya un président de la république qui
essaye de tenir les promesses qu'il a
fait pendant sa campagne et notamment
sur les réformes à engager un conte les
qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime pas qu'on
les trouve légitime ou pas mais pour une
fois où il ya prénom qui fait ce qu'il a
dit il ça ça provoque une rupture et ça
provoque un choc est probablement non
seulement les réformes doivent pas avoir
un minimum d'adhésion en tout cas des
procès qui alors était que le
gouvernement ait mal expliqué sa réforme
des retraites ça me paraît tellement
évident que bon c'est pas la peine de
sept ans dans là dessus et quelques
mesures ont passé des jours de grève des
fois la pédagogie et défauts de
communication et quelles conditions en
plus leur échec du référendum le
principe du référendum a été actée on va
voir si dans la fin avant la fin de
mandature nous avons des référendums et
impacter les bloquée au sénat après on
pourra voilà parce que c'est senna qui
bloque on pourra pourra juger donc si si
valve la démocratie participative que
tout le monde souhaite et qui est allé
remettre et à des médicaments à la
violence politique dont nous parlons
actuellement à ce principe de donner la
parole aux citoyens de faire participer
directement au lieu de leur imposer par
le haut un certain nombre de décisions
on va voir si ça rentre dans les faits
ils s'arment dans les faits probablement
ça va régler beaucoup de tension et
beaucoup de problèmes parce que ce qu'
il faut dire pour compléter les propos
c'est que emmanuel macron a été le
premier à promettre à promettre 7 ce
changement de forme de démocratie avec
la démocratie participative est
effectivement le fait qu'il avance avec
son procès de la participation citoyenne
moi j'en appelle au sénat pour que
effectivement cette loi
constitutionnelle aille jusqu'au bout et
qu'on discute de cette démocratie
participative au sein de la démocratie
représentative
je pense qu'il faut changer la façon de
faire de la politique en france
et là j'en appelle à tous les partis
politiques pas simplement celui d'
emmanuel macron il faut revoir cette
façon de les partis politiques ne faut
ne font plus leur travail de
concertation auprès des citoyens les
gens se désintéressent totalement de la
politique
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il faut clairement redonner cette parole
aux citoyens et pour revenir sur la
situation des violences dites policière
effectivement nous avons eu aussi un
changement de la manière de manifester
clairement cette manifestation des
gilets jaunes c'est un cas unique en
france c'est une nouvelle façon de
manifester on manifeste pour beaucoup de
choses tire le pouvoir d'achat on
manifeste pour les retraites en même
temps ça va être le prix de l'essence
ses terres qu'il ya des demandes et d
une contestation qui est au delà d'un
seul sujet comme les retraites c'est
pour ça que c'est très compliqué aussi
pour nos forces de l'ordre et si on
regarde avec objectivité des choses si
on regarde dans d'autres grandes
démocraties je pense notamment aux états
unis
c'est mille morts par an par la police à
cause de la police l'a transmise il omet
bien le siège est à vienne avait la même
philosophie dumas bien sûr qu'on n'a pas
la même mais en france si un seul blessé
et un blessé demeure un seul mort est un
mort de trop
oui mais il faut prendre en
considération tout de même qu'au delà de
la formation qui à mon sens essentiel il
faut aussi saluer l'engagement des
forces de l'ordre qui font un boulot
extraordinaire
au vu de ce qu'on vit actuellement dans
le pays qui exige les ordres a priori de
suivre les ordres 200 à 2000 quelques
roses pas de la campagne ce soit à
l'ordre du premier ministre du président
de la république
le policier qui tue un manifestant sa
banane et kaïser l'annuel mal bien sûr
après effectivement la cassure est
l'enfermement et c'est le fait que les
manifestants ne puissent plus sortir
effectivement ça c'est des ordres clairs
et des techniques pour pour de
dispersion qui sont peut-être pas
forcément adaptées au cas de nos
manifestations plus rien fait pour une
légère bruine je pensais pas un ordre le
croche pattes mais c'est le coup la
conséquence d'un sentiment de dollars
donc ça vient d'eux pas totalement non
plus je crois par hasard
y'a quand même des policiers qui ont été
traduits en justice oui 2 pour ces qui
ont été discutées avec les policiers du
poste
j'ai des policiers je l'accueille j'ai
discuté des policiers qui me disait
savez on reçoit des consignes plus
strictes pour ces manifestants là que
dès qu'on sait que les conseils que nous
avons quand nous devons aller dans
certains quartiers où là il n'ya pas des
manifestants qui avec qui manifestent ou
qu'ils perdent de l'argent pour défendre
des droits les leurs ou ceux de leurs
enfants qui font du trafic de drogue qui
font de la criminalité etc
et si vous voulez il ya quand même un
deux poids deux mesures parce que on se
dit mais attendez il ya des situations
qui dérivent complètement dans certains
quartiers français on a l'impression
qu'il ya plus du tout de loi plus d'état
plus de plus de police a plus rien et
ils font l'épreuve
ils font souvent ce qu'ils peuvent et
d'un autre côté on une espèce de long
attendions une hyper répression ou de
techniques de maintien de l'ordre qui
sont faites pour pour de déprimer les
manifestants pour l'utiliser avec le
lacrymogènes en permanence et ça ce deux
poids deux mesures est insupportable moi
je voudrais dire je pense qu'il ya un
phénomène de violence politique qui a
commencé il ya un point générateur de
tous c'est ce qui s'est passé 4 février
2008 à versailles
quand on a bafoué le référendum sur la
constitution européenne on a fait passer
ce 4 février 2008 par le parlement par
le congrès le traité de lisbonne qu'on
s'est pas rendu compte de l'ondé de choc
que ça allait produire dans les années
et les décennies suivantes
parce que ça a été dur inédit d'une
violence inouïe inouïe ya quant à lui un
énorme une énorme campagne avant le
référendum de 2005 tout le monde tout ce
qu'ils ont vécu son souviennent le
peuple français à voter clairement et ça
a été annulé comme ça en catimini par le
peuple gauche droite centre et unique
qui était d'accord entre annulée par le
parlement à partir de là les gens se
sont dit mais attendez il est grand
alors ils l'ont compris quelques années
plus tard progressivement un médard de
crédibilité énorme c'est un terrible
c'est même un coup de couteau un coup de
canif dans le pacte républicain et
démocratique
on s'est dit mais attendez on vote pour
quoi attendez on nous demande la parole
on vote en référendum et c'est annulé
par 500 personnes 900 personnes avaient
uni qui pensent qu'elles sont plus
intelligentes que 40 millions 45
millions d'électeurs à lorient au
maquereau n'est pas responsable
il a été élu
c'est quoi je demande à aimer toujours
dire le seul problème c'est un espoir de
changement ou charles emmanuel macron
mais ça a commencé bien avant mais bien
sûr il est accro mcgraw hill a il a
continué voire aggraver cela il est la
continuité de continuer voire aggraver
parce que moi j'ai pas vu sous macron de
référendum
j'ai pas vu de vraie concertation j'ai
vu le d'agglo là j'ai vu l'arrivée
justement moi j'ai vu le grand débat
abeba c'est un grand débat ya des médias
le grand débat pour moi il a été
l'occasion pour lui d'apparaître secteur
par samedi à la télévision sur toutes
les chaînes ça n'a objectivement servi à
rien moi j'ai vu des mini ce même chien
pas pourquoi la cité qu'ils allaient
faire des émissions grand public
je crois que chez cyril hanouna pendant
trois heures à la révision seul devant
un tableau avec son stylo et elle noté à
la fin nous avait dit c'était en janvier
2019 vous pouvez retrouvez l'émission
elle sort de l'émission ou trois ans dix
ans je vois si cet engagement écrite au
stabilo sur un par la ministre elle-même
c'est cet engagement je vous assure que
la plus un an après non seulement ils
sont pas tenues mais là plus personne
qui en parle alors vous savez les gens
ils sont pas idiots ils ont vu cette
émission ceux qui ont vu cette émission
comme moi qui ont entendu parler le
lendemain qui ont regardé la vidéo mais
se disent mais un an plus tard c'était
quoi donc c'était juste de la com et et
là on se dit on nous prend vraiment pour
des c ie riaillé croisions quand on nous
prend pour des idiots plus des
conditions de vie objectivement très
difficile pas ça peut produire de la
violence
ça justifie pas l'excusé c'est
d'expliquer des policiers qui ne sont
pas sanctionnés il ya eu des sanctions
administratives à on a parlé ces
derniers temps de 2000 sanctions 2000
maintenant on a vérifié ses mille
manquements sanctionné donc des
policiers 337 sanctions qui vont des
avertissements aux conseils aux
sanctions disciplinaires mais ça reste
administrative c'est vrai que faute qu'a
finalement vont en justice et magali
content quand on revient aux violences
on oublie aussi que des centaines de
policiers ont été blessés
c'est vrai et centaines de policiers 197
forces de l'ordre blessés ne vous rendez
compte l'an dernier non c'est à peu près
la moitié
gendarmes pompiers beaucoup sur
et dessus c'est celle de 1200
manifestants
c'est énorme c'est vrai que l'on doit
plus arriver à des chiffres pareils ça
ça ne doit plus exister ça aurait
puisque finalement les policiers ont les
mêmes problèmes où ce sont des français
ils vont mettre la sûreté des citoyens
il n'ya pas bien sûr et ils sont en
grande souffrance on va quand même
rappeler ces chiffres en 2018 ils
étaient 35 à se suicider 59 suicide en
2019 une hausse de 70% en un an et déjà
plusieurs cas notamment la semaine
dernière deux personnes qui se sont
suicidées que celui parce que la
violence policy la violence face à la
police des manifestants à comment tu as
comme quand même augmenté largement
quand on voit les jets de projectiles de
pavés sur les forces de l'ordre où on a
vu des manifestations où c'était
relativement violent alors je ne dis pas
que ces jeunes évidemment mais il ya les
black blocks
on est qui joue ce rôle donc de violence
nation qui je n'arrive que dans la
société en général
on est dans une société qui est
nettement plus violente parce qu'elle a
pu l'être
on le voit avec des airs nombre d'élus
mêmes locaux qui se font agresser je
suis voire tuer puisqu'on a eu une année
dernière quand même le maire de signes
qui est décédé un poésie percuté un
câlin à policier est percuté par un
camion
voilà les ministères défoncer avec des
des tractopelles ou pas des tractopelles
ménard damon charles des transpalettes
exactement voilà c'est tout ça avec une
police qui quand même gardé un
sang-froid et des crs notamment qui sont
formés pour cela qu'ils gardent un sang
froid hors du commun on rester avec nous
on continue ce débat sur luge à usage de
la force policière et militaire par
l'exécutif est elle bien adaptées face à
la menace
et pour quel résultat emmanuel macron a
convoqué un sommet sur le sahel cette
semaine à pau on en parle dans quelques
minutes rester avec nous
[Musique]
haïm et des pays africains à l'euro
c'est une évidence bêtise la france a
intérêt à maintenir de français parce
que c'est l'un de ces rares instruments
qu'ils ont de protection de ses intérêts
économiques en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question au ladakh avec
fixe avec une offre mais c'est est-ce
que c'est bip monnaie le sujet
aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas d'avoir
une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de qui a entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
ce
à
mais
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un coup
très fusionnelle à ce que vous viviez un
peu dans la peur avec tout ce qui est
des menaces oui d intimidation comme
brûler les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment jeune ans je pense que il y
croyait pas ceux qui ont été assassinés
étaient les politiques du journal il
était l'âme de ce journal et oui ils ont
tué charlie je voulais pas que tignes où
ce soit une victime
je ne voulais pas que son nom soit
associé à 8 in youth la victime de
charlie je voulais que on se dit à
tignes où le grand dessinateur c'est ça
qui est bien avec un artiste c'est qu'un
artiste tant qu'on publie son travail
l'artiste est vivant
[Musique]
oh
pôle it mag la suite avec nouveaux
contributeurs aurélie gros florian
philippot est notre invité michel
scarbonchi ancien député européen et
spécialiste de l'afrique
lundi emmanuel macron à réunir dans le
sud ouest de la france les cinq chefs
d'état africains du g5 sahel engagés
dans la lutte antiterroriste et après la
mort de 13 soldats français au mali en
novembre dernier emmanuel macron leur
avait demandé de formaliser leurs
demandes sur l'implication de l'armée
française au sahel alors que les
militaires sont de plus en plus critiqué
le sur ce terrain écouter
j'attends d'eux qu'ils clarifient et
formalisent leur demande à l'égard de la
france et de la communauté
internationale souhaite yves notre
présence ont-ils besoin de nous je veux
des réponses claires et assumé sur ces
questions je ne peux ni ne veux avoir
des soldats français sur quelques sols
du sahel que ce soit alors même que
l'ambiguïté persiste à l'égard de
mouvements anti français donc et bayonne
maquereau a demandé une clarification on
l'a vu cette semaine à michel scarbonchi
pour vous là la demande a été entendue
par les chefs d'état africains oui pis
ils ont réaffirmé au cours du sommet de
pau qu'il voulait que la france les aide
à résoudre le problème auquel il était
confronté
nous avons au sahel nous avons la
difficulté suivante sur les pays
concernés comme le le niger le mali
surtout le mali le burkina faso qui est
ce qu emmanuel à craquer la zone des
trois frontières voilà l'entreprise
nous avons nous avons une faiblesse qui
est celle des chefs d'état concernés de
ces pays parce qu'il joue qui sont non
ils sont d'abord contesté socialement
politiquement ils sont ils ont ils sont
impopulaires et vous pouvez pas gagner
une guerre si vous n'avez pas l'adhésion
de ces peuples pour qui nous sommes
censés combattre et que nous sommes
censés protéger sans oublier que en les
protégeant nous nous protégeons aussi
parce que je veux rappeler ici que là la
frontière africaine que nous tenons aux
scènes et la première digue anti
terroriste pour l'europe pour l'ensemble
de l'europe
s'il est passé de frontières c'est que
ce sont les mêmes terroristes michels
car mon fils a on parle de notre menace
en france où ils sont les mêmes long
mais ce sont bien sûr ce sont les mêmes
plutôt du maghreb
non non mais ce sont les mêmes nouveau
nom d'al-qaïda et l'état islamique sont
implantés aux scènes fortement implantés
il profite de la pauvreté pour recruter
des jeunes etc à des envolées
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'effectifs parce qu'au début ils
n'étaient pas nombreux il devient de
plus en plus nombreux et donc nous
devons nous devons faire face à une
action militaire
et en même temps à la nécessité comme
l'a rappelé le président apo d'une
action de développement économique parce
que l'un va pas sans l'autre
si nous voulons réussir à gagner cette
guerre il faut qu'on aide ces pays n'a à
se développer
pas seulement la france l'union
européenne
l'onu l'onu parce que ce qu'est ce qui
est quand même terrible c'est que nous
sommes seuls sont des soldats français
qui payent le prix du sang en afrique
pour protéger l'europe sont pas des
allemands sont pas des danois sont pas
des bennes cent des français et donc il
est temps que l'europe s'implique donc
le président avait demandé à la fois
l'implication des états africains sang
enserre années en vain pour l'instant
pour l'instant pas moins de répondre à
ses appels en ondes dans le cadre de
l'opération tabou cas vous avez le
danemark la hollande la belgique la
norvège qui ont répondu positivement
alors commencé quelques forces spéciales
ce sont des bons oui mais ce serait le
maquereau on va regarder d'ailleurs les
forces en présence au sahel
j'ai fait réagir florian philippot est
ce que il ya eu plusieurs questions qui
se sont posées suite à la mort d des
soldats français au mali est ce qu'il
faut se retirer du sahel la france est
seule sur place at elle les moyens de
continuer cette guerre non moi je suis
très fier de ce que font nos soldats
là-bas je suis très fière que l'un d'eux
que fait la france
je n'ai rien à dire à ce qu'a dit la le
président ma république
c'est une oeuvre une mission absolument
indispensable que moi j'ai soutenu
personnellement depuis le début s'est
élancé sous françois hollande s'en
rappelle on l'a payé déjà et nos soldats
l'ont payé du prix du sang déjà très
lourdement
ce sont des sacrifices et ce qu'ils font
c'est absolument indispensable pour
notre sécurité
donc je suis parfaitement d'accord par
ailleurs avec l'idée qu'il faut une
politique de co-développement
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et
compris aussi avec des acteurs privés il
n'y a pas que les états pourront pas le
fallait le faire seul et l'onu qui
normalement devrait s'impliquer
davantage là dedans
tout doit aller ensemble et c'est vrai
qu' on ne peut pas accepter en parallèle
ce climat d' insulte contre la france
qui qui n'est pas admissible à qui n'est
pas admissible s'il ya des malentendus
on peut les lever on peut avoir des
débats on peut parler beaucoup de choses
mais moi ça me gêne je veux d'aider des
dirigeants français qui défendent
l'honneur aussi de la france et de
l'armée française va subir ok
oui là dessus il a bien fait enfin
convoqué chez les a invité à un sommet
c'est vrai qu'au début il avait senti ça
comme une contrainte mais on n'a pas à
subir ce flot d'insultés et ensuite il
ya une instrumentalisation là-bas de
l'opinion publique contre la france qui
était indigne avec des fakes nous lancer
des fausses informations quand les
militaires français qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux y compris en afrique etc
non il faut rétablir la vérité voilà ce
qu'on fait ça protège les africains et
ça protège les français les européens et
beaucoup d'autres populations et on doit
être fier de cela alors voila moi je
pense par ailleurs que la france a
intérêt à avoir environ dix ans mais sol
de fait on est seul
là où à peu près ce qu'il doit nous
obliger non pas à crier en permanence on
est seul et donc on doit espérer des
alliés qui peut-être ne viendront jamais
ça doit nous obliger est responsable
nous même et avoir une défense et
l'industrie de défense autonome
indépendante et haut niveau ce qui
suppose d'investir davantage dans la
défense nationale à terme il faudrait
déjà réatteindrai 2% du pib le plus
rapidement possible et à terme peut-être
au bout de cinq ou dix ans atteindre 3%
du pib
parce qu'une si on veut vraiment pesé
défense il faut 3% du pib dans le budget
de la défense nationale et avoir une
industrie de défense en parallèle qu'ils
soient autonomes
je ne sais pas si on va y revenir mais
une industrie défense nationale
aujourd'hui elle est en train d'être
européaniser ou plus exactement elle est
en train d'être germaniser aussi bien
sur le terreau est ce que le naval que
l'aérien et bien écoutez ça c'est
irresponsable
quand on achète par ailleurs nos fusils
en belgique en autriche ou ailleurs il
n'est plus capable de produire des
fusils français quand même alors qu'on a
une des plus grand nombre on garde parmi
les dix plus grande armée du monde et
qu'on est une politique en alors on vise
une politique mondiale une politique
étrangère mondiale et qu'on produise
plus l'armement
de base qu'est le fusil pour un soldat
ça voyez ça c'est pas responsables voilà
donc autant les choix politique et
diplomatique et politique étrangère en
afrique je les soutiens autant
l'infrastructure qui va autour pour
notre armée pour nos soldats pour leur
sécurité et pour la force qu incarne la
france je le comte je le condamne et je
ne le soutiens pas on va écouter
emmanuel macron impôts justement qui a
décidé en tout cas d'envoyer des forces
supplémentaires écoutez j'ai décidé
d'engager des capacités de combat
supplémentaires 220 militaires pour
amorcer cette dynamique viendront
gonfler les troupes d'ores et déjà
présentes sur le terrain de barkan tous
les pays partenaires qui le souhaitent
sont les bienvenus pour rejoindre cette
dynamique partenaires européens
partenaires africains et internationaux
et je veux ici remercier en particulier
nos partenaires européens qui ont
accepté de s'engager dans la tasse force
takouba qui rassemblera d'ici quelques
mois des forces spéciales de plusieurs
pays européens je pense est une démarche
extrêmement importante
on voit là donc des renforts
supplémentaires alors que la france ne
sera pas forcément tout seul on a
entendu le le président emmanuel macron
mais pour l'instant c'est le cas aurélie
gros la stratégie militaire au sahel est
elle la bonne
on voit que les américains veulent se
désengager également florence parly est
au sahel demain elle sera à washington
a priori dans les prochains jours la
france va réussir à rallier ses alliés
selon vous je pense qu'il est
indispensable que la france rallye ses
alliés ont parlé tout à l'heure de
digues
effectivement c'est la première digue la
frontière du sahel la première digue
avant la montée vers l'europe de groupes
islamiques qui pourraient qui pourrait
mettre en péril la sécurité sur notre
notre territoire même si c'est déjà le
cas on le sait très bien
par ailleurs les annonces des manuels de
macron que je soutiens fortement
quant à sa présence au sahel ont été
essentiels et ce sommet augure de bonnes
choses qu'on sait que ce sentiment
anti-français qui était monté de venez
quand même insupportable pour nos
moniteurs sur place que les
gouvernements en place ne pas ne pas les
interroger
qu'ils ne prennent pas position et
laisse la france en fin de compte s'en
prendre plein la figure de manière
inacceptable
ce n'était plus possible par contre je
pense qu'il faut vraiment aujourd'hui
que cette cette puissance militaire
installé donc barkan soient soutenus par
des actions de développement mais de
développement auprès des populations
parce qu'aujourd'hui lutter contre le
terrorisme par une action militaire ne
suffit pas
si nous ne développons pas les villages
sur place d'abba nous créons d'autres
djihadistes parce qu'ils sont inclus
dans la population c'est pour ça que
nous avons besoin du soutien des
politiques locaux évidemment mais aussi
de la question de développement que ce
soit le développement des collectivités
territoriales développement grâce à
l'union européenne
grâce au gouvernement français
évidemment aux grandes entreprises qui
investissent effectivement sur le
territoire africain mais en tout cas
tout cela ça doit être gérée en réseau
et ça doit être une co-construction avec
les peuples moi je reviens du mali il ya
quelques semaines j'étais au mali en
même temps que les manifestations anti
français c'est vrai que il y a un amour
d amour c'est cesser c'est palpable
parce que les africains ne voit pas
d'amélioration en tout cas dont parce
que il termine régler les groupes
terroristes
les africains ne voit pas d'amélioration
je pense que sur le territoire français
si on parle aussi de la france il ya
aussi quelque chose d'essentiel il
faudrait que l'association française de
développement aille dans le même sens
que le ministère des affaires étrangères
je parle en termes de subventions parce
qu'on sait que celles qui développent le
plus des choses
locale qui concerne les peuples sont des
collectivités territoriales et des
collectivités territoriales qui crée
décoller des coopérations en réseau avec
les collectivités par exemple au mali
sur place des collectivités des communes
des cercles donc c'est l'association
française de développement aujourd'hui
refusent de donner des subventions aux
collectivités françaises qui font du
développement en zone rouge
alors moi j'aimerais qu'on me présente
juste une chose c'est comment vous
voulez lutter contre le djihadisme
l'état islamique dans ces territoires là
si on nous empêche de faire nous empêche
de faire du développement
la présence militaire seule ne tiendra
pas et elle peut être rejoint par tous
les pays européens
s'il n'ya pas de développement ce sera
une catastrophe et nos militaires ne
s'en sortiront port michel scarbonchi la
présence française on le voit on a vu
ces manifestants en tout cas africain
qui est qu'ils ne veulent pas de cette
présence parce qu'elles ont veut nîmes
plutôt qu'elle ne règle cette situation
la présence française c'est un argument
aussi pour les groupes terroristes pour
continuer le combat
mais je vous là dessus sur la gérance
l'intervention française etc
d'où le fait colonialiste nous sommes
une à une armée colonialiste et sam est
ce qu'un ennemi sur place pour ses
comptes terroriste également à combattre
bien popo a marqué un tournant tactique
militaire très important c'est à dire
que nous avons pris acte de la faiblesse
des armées du mali du niger du burkina
faso d'en parler ou l'inexistence de ces
armes et caetera
seuls les tchadiens et les mauritaniens
ont des armes est capable de mener les
combats contre les théories c est qu on
fire et gras grâce à grâce à eux
d'ailleurs si nous avons pu tenir comme
nous tenons avec 4500 hommes il faut il
faut il faut il faut souligner l'armée
malienne
non non le promet le problème c'est que
mal encadré mal formés mal équipés et
c'est vous à rattraper pas en deux ans
un héritage de 50 ans d'absence
militaires pourquoi parce que ces pays
dan avait pas de véritable armée puisque
les chefs d'état et peur d'un coup
d'état
donc il y avait une garde présidentielle
il ne développait pas l'armée donc on
peut pas rattraper le retard qu'a été
pris donc il a été décidé de faire quoi
à pau il était décidé de former des
forces spéciales c'est à dire au lieu de
jouer le nom
on va jouer la qualité donc les
commandos et cetera donc on est en train
de développer tout cela avec l'académie
militaire des forces spéciales qui a été
créé en côte d'ivoire pour toute
l'afrique de l'ouest
et je pense que ces forces là plus les
forces spéciales françaises européennes
sachant qu'une nouvelle stratégie
changera la nature de la guerre
probablement salit on va on va cibler à
cibler l'année ayant à l'esprit que nous
sommes sur une superficie qui est
l'équivalent de l'europe et que nous
avons que 5000 hommes pour tenir
l'équivalent de l'europe avec le
renseignement américain qui lui a dit
voilà il a été engagé donc ce qui est au
repli général qui est en repli général
le double non allemands à l'envoi de
renforts au sahel florian philippot
qu'est ce que ça dit de la défense
européenne qui est si chère à emmanuel
macron pour l'instant les allemands ils
sont surtout occupés à récupérer notre
avantage technologique
ils l'ont fait déjà sur le char leclerc
puisqu'on sait qu'il ya eu fusion dans k
md s de nexter dont qui était le
français en avez une au charbon
maintenant ils seront franco-allemand
serre que nous s'ils voulaient là dessus
on n'a vraiment pas été malin parce que
nous avons accepté les fusions comme
cela sur des entreprises sur lesquelles
nous avions une avance technologique
les allemands ils ont joué leur intérêt
national ils ont vu ils regardent
également ils sont assez pragmatique à
hirgars nous est ce qu il leur manque un
secteur technologique et il propose dans
ce qu'elle a toujours une coopération
européenne toujours il fonctionne
toujours comme cela ce qui en fait
souvent une coopération franco allemande
où on rajoute un peu d'italiens et
d'espagnols et on dit que c'est européen
et ça devient en bout de 5 10 ans ça
devient allemand très souvent et dans
majoritaire dont elle veut aller au feu
bardon n'y a personne
bah non bah c'est plus confortable de
récupérer les emplois la recherche
recherche et développement et puis une
entreprise un fleuron que d'envoyer des
soldats mourir sur offrons évidemment
c'est ça c'est là aujourd'hui c'est la
stratégie allemande je leur en veux pas
à eux ils défendent une stratégie
nationale
j'en veux à nos dirigeants qui laisse
faire on pourrait citer la même chose
d'ailleurs pour dassault dassault on a
notre propre avion de combat de marc
nous a déjà dit ce seront forcément des
avions franco allemand je sais pas
pourquoi parce qu'on sait faire depuis
très bien des avions français
mais il faut que ce soit des avions
franco allemand je sais en réalité
pourquoi c'est que les allemands veulent
avoir là aussi la technologie
tout cela se comprend du point de vue
allemand ne se comprend pas
de vue français et en parallèle vous
avez raison effectivement il n'envoie
pas un seul soldat
ils ont refusé de participer aux
opérations maritimes de sécurité de la
méditerranée alors alors si vous voulez
si on pouvait au moins prendre acte de
ces refus en dix ans attendez vous
refusez ça donc nous on va arrêter les
coopérations sur l'industrie de défense
qui sont quand même pas à notre avantage
mais plutôt aux vôtres ce serait quand
même pas mal de temps en temps de
montrer un peu les muscles on le fait
pas on ne fait jamais de toute façon
face à l'allemagne ne sais pas pourquoi
on est à plat ventre depuis 30 ans face
à ce pays eh bien écoutez là on va le
payer cher
voilà on va le payer cher et dans cinq
dix ans les protocoles d'accord ne
tiendrons pareil comme d'habitude on
verra des emplois et de la recherche et
développement partir de l'autre côté et
la contradiction c'est que demain est
lui un sommet à berlin pour le dossier
hypersensible de la libye on se demande
pourquoi le sommet a lieu à berlin
d'ailleurs parce que en dehors d'avoir
une comme la conférence de paris bien
sûr la ligne 1 tout a échoué ce criirad
a échoué ce la celle saint cloud a
échoué
dubaï a échoué palerme échoué et c'est
parce qu'il faut être deux pour faire un
accord aujourd'hui vous avez et donc
c'est bizarre est paradoxal de voir les
allemands s'engager dans une conférence
à berlin sur la libye alors que ils ne
sont parties prenantes à rien sur le
territoire africain ou en méditerranée
donc c'est bon mais on n'est pas un
paradoxe près en europe parce qu'elle
privilégie peut-être la voie
diplomatique qui est aussi essentiel
dans la régulation à la problématique
aussi et qu'on de l'europe est la non
compréhension de l'europe c'est qu'à
partir du moment où on a un pays qui est
capable de ne pas s'allier à un autre
pays où la présence est maintenant fait
mais peut-être que stratégie tout
simplement les allemands sont
pragmatiques nous là on ne croit pas que
ce soit pas l'agilité remet en effet
annoncé que je pense que l'allemagne n'a
pas la même conscience que nous de
l'importance du terrorisme et je pensais
et bien qu'ils étaient présents en
afrique etc est depuis longtemps un il
avait des colonies n'oublions pas et
aimé je suis frappé mois par la sepaq
l'allemagne mais la lâcheté de l'europe
et l'impuissance de l'europe sur le
dossier libyen
puisqu'il devrait nous intéresser au
premier rang puisque qu'est ce qui se
passe en libye et qui est la cause aussi
de tout ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
en libye en libye c'est aussi la
première protection de l'armée française
c'est l'alibi du maréchal haftar c'est à
dire en sécurisant toute la libye comme
il a fait en contrôlant 95% du
territoire il empêcher que nos soldats
puissent être pris à revers avec la
frontière libyenne
et avec le niger c'est pas lui qui est
reconnu par l'onu et c'est alors le
problème est là aussi en grande finale
ces canaux est nu l'onu soutient un
personnage totalement fantoche qui est
aux mains des milices islamistes et on
soutient donc un personnage qui est
allié au terrorisme et mieux que ça la
r2 gagnent vient d'exporter près de 500
ha minh miliciens syriens qui ont
combattu nos alliés kurdes au mois de
novembre et qui vient de débarquer par
avion à tripoli pour combattre le marché
tarde t il or on ne dit rien l'otan ne
dit rien alors qu'à turquie est membre
de l'otan moi on est en est en plein
chaos on parle on parle de l'âne de la
prérogative du chef de l'état lui usage
de la force donc on a parlé des
policiers des militaires effectivement
engagés dans cette opération c'est l'on
note une info 583 emplois vacants depuis
le 1er janvier 2019 l'armée a du mal à
recruter
c'est ces derniers ces derniers mois il
manque plusieurs postes d'officiers des
demandes officielles donc dans tout
l'est dans toutes les armes contre
l'armée de l'air la marine
toutes les toutes les armes sont
concernés par ce manque d'effectif
du coup ce week end l'armée a fait une
opération séduction avec une fabrique
défense c'est comme ça que florence
parly l'avait annoncé pour attirer les
jeunes pourquoi pourquoi selon vous
aurélie gros cette filière n'intéresse
plus les jeunes aujourd'hui je pense que
cette filière a subi a subi une
désertification à partir du moment où le
service militaire obligatoire a été
arrêté alors on parle d'un temps c'était
sous jacques chirac donc ça fait un
certain temps maintenant mais on sait
que les effets prennent toujours un
grand nombre d'années
clairement le service militaire
permettait à des jeunes de découvrir des
professions et effectivement quand on
voit les violences qui se passe dans le
monde je pense que nos jeunes ne sont
plus intéressés par l'environnement que
d'aller se faire tuer par des
djihadistes je crois qu'il y avait une
certaine forme de peur aussi à travers
ses choix l'a donc mais pour moi la
première des causes et l'arrêt du
service militaire obligatoire
alors il ya aussi le fait qu'il soit
tiré plus faire des filières privés etc
de sécurité c'est un métier qui n'attire
plus par son attractivité aussi
pécuniaire peut-être un michel
scarbonchi peut-être bien que les
militaires en opérations extérieures
sans on déprime et peuvent doubler leur
salaire
parce que aussi on a dit le chef de
l'état était
à la fin de l'année a réveillonné aux
côtés des troupes et les a rassurés tout
est sur cette fameuse retraite je pense
pas qu'au niveau de nos forces spéciales
on est un problème d'effectif de
problème d'effectif je pense pas nous
avons toujours une capacité
d'intervention de projection extérieure
très fortes sommes même les seuls en
europe à la voir hélas voilà avec les
mains peu les britanniques mais qui sont
plus en europe mais moi je je suis
étonné par ces chiffres parce que je
pensais que l'armée qui fléchit depuis
un an je suis étonné à la télévision
partout
je suis étonné je vois d'emplois vacants
très court mais les emplois vacants
c'est pas forcément un problème de
recrutement
ça peut être un problème d'organisation
en interne ou en tout cas il ya une
fabrique défense qui a lieu ce week end
lui en permanence il faut recruter
beaucoup de moi il ya de gros besoin
je pense que mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même un gros attrait il ya des
vagues de recrutement qui marche très
bien je pense qu'il ya quand même plus
un problème de mon annonce des emplois
et on se rend compte qu'un an plus tard
583 ne sont pas remplies peut-être pour
faire simplement des économies
budgétaires jeu train plutôt que ce soit
ça alors c'est lors du du coup de gueule
à présent
vous aurez une minute chacun un coup de
gueule pour vous aurélie gros ça
concerne l' annonce de la candidature à
la présidentielle de marine le pen cette
semaine oui c'est assez étonnant à deux
ans et demi de la prochaine année des
prochaines élections présidentielles que
marine le pen annonce cette candidature
et je trouve ça assez pitoyable de sa
part on sent vraiment une
instrumentalisation de la campagne
présidentielle au profit de ses
candidats aux campagnes à la campagne
municipale qui va arriver on sait très
bien que marine le pen son seul
programme
c'est justement elle la professionnelle
des campagnes présidentielles il n'y a
rien dans son programme et elle vient
donner un coup de main à ses amis qui se
présente aux municipales
mais je trouve que ce n'est pas le même
sujet je pense que les français en ont
marre de cette manière de faire de la
politique et d'instrumentaliser tout au
profit d'une étiquette et d'un parti
politique et pour mon florian philippot
un coup de gueule sur la baisse du
livret a le 1er février prochain gagne
0,75 qui est déjà très bas à 0,5 pas
possible donc 0 5% donc très en dessous
de l'inflation donc le si vous voulez je
pense que je suis moi j'étais surpris je
pensais qu'ils allaient au moins laisser
0,75 dans le contexte de grève sur les
retraites pouvoir d'achat gilet jaune et
non ils ont quand même fait je le vois
comme une provocation
enfin tout cas ça va avantager les
banques et ça va désavantager les 55
millions de français c'est le lion un
livret à livret préféré des français
bah oui on va écouter onze ans après et
c'est quoi il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'autres choix de toute façon il ya ce
livre est à 0,5 qui n'ont que nous
rapporte quasiment plus rien moins que
l'inflation donc on s'appauvrit en
mettant de l'argent même en épargants
banques et au passage on engraisse un
peu plus des établissements bancaires
jeu c'est une provocation dans le
contexte social actuel
honnêtement c'est une provocation et une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat par l'ustke
c'est une baisse de pouvoir d'achat
claire et nette démontrable très
facilement dans un contexte déjà
compliquée merci florian film merci no
mercy aurélie grossir votre contribution
à cette émission merci michel scarbonchi
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france c'est la fin de deux pôles it mag
restez avec nous
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles welsh podium m6
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain oriente et c'est un univers qui
nous permet justement d'aller encore
plus loin dans cet état d'introspection
et de travail sur le corps et aussi sur
les plus on va être dans l'instant prix